the delta variant emerged in india's
ferocious second wave
leaving its mark on millions
it since crossed the world sending
infection rates soaring
threatening a return to normal
and playing havoc with children's lives
too
from school closures to long covet and
even severe illnesses
more and more studies show from great
britain for example
that one percent of children are
hospitalized that's not trivial
just how dangerous is delta for children
we should make our own decisions based
on the evidences available to us
and the overwhelming evidence is that
this is a mar disease in children
and should we be stepping up the race to
vaccinate them
hello and welcome to our copy 19 special
i'm monica jones in berlin where kids
are currently enjoying the summer
holidays schools are closed
giving parents the chance to spend time
with their youngsters and
protect them from getting infected with
kobe 19
but what happens when schools reopen
many fear that kids could then be
exposed to the highly contagious delta
variant
the news from the uk where the variant
is sending
even kids now to hospital has
intensified the debate about vaccines
at the same time scientists are still
trying to fully understand the
impact sars kovi 2 is having on kids
while the virus always seems to be one
step
ahead
for more i'm joined by jacob armand he's
an attending physician at the university
children's hospital in dress
good to have you with us first of all
how dangerous is the delta variant for
children
hi thanks for having me so um
currently we actually we don't have any
data that the delta variant is more
dangerous for the individual
child than the alpha variant that
was prominent before or the wild type
for that matter
so at this point if you look at
hospitalization rates if you look at
kids admitted to the icu nothing changed
with the emerge of the delta variant
the delta variant is more transmissible
so you will have
more people overall and for that matter
more children who
do get infected but the individual risk
did not change with the emerge of the
delta variant
right so does this mean that kids
suffering from covet 19
at your clinic right now that the number
of kids
that you're looking after there hasn't
changed or are there more kids
at your hospital right now because of
the delta variant
so actually currently we do not have a
single kid with
covet 19 in the hospital that's good to
know and
um obviously the numbers are still quite
low in germany um
but there are kids um infected with the
delta variant in dresden and the
surrounding areas
but none of them has been sick enough to
um get to the hospital
um and so and also if you look at
data from the uk where the delta variant
emerged earlier then in germany
you don't see more kids being admitted
to the hospital
due to covet 19 now with delta being
more prevalent
but we heard that uh certainly the
symptoms
of of adults uh getting coveted 19
through the delta variant vary to the
original strain now you're saying just
to clarify that
that there is no difference whatsoever
with children
no difference that we could determine at
this point so we do have for example
a national registry where all
hospitalized children with covet 19
are reported and
we don't find any difference in the last
month compared to the months before
and this is the same is true if you talk
to pediatricians in the uk for example
so they don't see a difference either
children do have mild symptoms usually
but they don't get very sick with the
delta right here
right uh i mean a lot uh point to the
fact that we
simply don't have enough data ups
because many studies including
yours of course that focus on children
uh but critics keep saying that there
are way too few test subjects and you
just
basically confirmed that uh does this
mean uh that
the studies if we can call them
ultimately
scientific guesswork and we don't really
know
well i think that's a bit of an
overstatement so i mean you're
right there are not as many
sick children than adults which is a
good sign but also that's a result right
so
if you don't have a lot of kids in the
hospital with code 19
at least you know kids don't get really
sick with covet 19.
um and if this doesn't change with the
new variant
then there's no reason to fear that this
new variant
everything will change for the children
in this particular setting
um in terms of um guesswork i mean
every study you do you can answer
usually one specific questions and there
are a lot of questions that remain
unanswered in this study and scientists
are very clear about that
however you do have a lot of different
studies from different countries and you
can look at the combination of the
studies and then make
very very um good assumptions about this
so
even if this one study doesn't have
enough
power to detect this and this if you
combine
10 15 20 different studies you usually
get a nice result
and just for comparison so for example
our school study we have 1500 students
included in this study
um the study to to approve the
the fisa bionic vaccine in adolescence
a thousand adolescents got vaccinated
with the
vaccine and a thousand got the placebo
so it's not that they are not studies
with
similar size studies in children and
adolescents that we can base our um
results
right so just very briefly because most
children
aren't vaccinated yet is that a problem
is this going to be a problem for them
um i don't so individually for them it's
not a big problem
as i said the risk for the individual
kid to
become severely ill with covet 19 is
absolutely minimal especially if you do
not have any pre-existing conditions
if their comorbidities is a bit
different but even then the risk
compared to all the population is very
very low
um so would it be beneficial to have
kids vaccinated to a higher degree in
terms of
overall transmission rate in the society
probably would help a little bit yes but
for the individual children it does not
make a huge difference um and
to me the important part is
if you in your country if your
vaccination program if you have to
choose between
um vaccinating adolescents or
let's say a 35 year old i would always
choose the 35 year old because
he has that much higher risk for any
covet related
sequelae compared to the child or the
adolescent
if you are in a place where you say okay
we do have now enough vaccines for
everybody and basically we don't know
what to do with them
yes that's then the place where you
should start vaccinating your
adolescence at this point i mean there's
no approved vaccine under 12 years old
but um not if you have prioritized those
and the other point that's very
important to me is i think there should
not be a connection between
school attendance and vaccination rate
in adolescence
we do know that the the negative effects
of school closures and school
restrictions are much higher than any
risk from covet for this age group so
um i think kids going to school is much
more important than having kids
vaccinated if you can do both that's
great
but if it's not possible they still
should go to school
well it certainly sounds like we do have
a choice here
which is not a bad thing jakub amman
from the university children's hospital
in dresden thank you so much
thank you so is every new variant of
calls for concern
time for your questions over to derek
[Music]
as the tsar's cov2 virus inevitably
continues to mutate
could it also mutate to become less
deadly
this is complicated but here goes the
short answer is
yes that could happen and and we hope it
will
but there's no guarantee um scientists
used to believe
that pathogens always evolved to grow
less deadly because it was thought a
deadly disease
is an ineffective disease the reasoning
was
that if a pathogen kills its host
especially if it kills that host
quickly then it lowers its own chances
of being passed on so less deadly
more transmissible variants should have
an evolutionary advantage right
well the problem with that logic is that
virulence can also be viewed as an
advantage because the sicker the host
grows
the more likely they are to give their
pathogen to someone else
since they're shedding more of it some
so we actually think there's kind of a
an evolutionary
trade-off between transmissibility
and virulence and and there are
certainly pathogens for instance
the tuberculosis bacterium that have
been infecting humans
for thousands of years yet still kill
large numbers of people to see what the
future
might hold for covet 19 therefore
scientists have been looking
at the other coronaviruses known to
infect
humans in particular the four that we
think have been doing it
for quite a while um they only cause
mild cold-like symptoms interestingly
that might have less to do with them and
more to do
with us especially with our children um
one theory is that repeated exposure
to those other coronaviruses in early
childhood
might be helping to prevent more severe
cases of the sicknesses they could
cause later in life if sars cove2
does become an endemic background
illness
in our societies then then later
generations of children
will be exposed to it early at an age
when it rarely makes you seriously ill
and
and that in turn should make subsequent
exposures
much less dangerous or at least that's
the hope
now meanwhile the delta variant is
driving a fourth
wave of the pandemic in france it now
accounts for up to 80 percent of new
cases there
the government plans to expand its list
of places that only vaccinated people
can enter
like the eiffel tower which just
reopened last week it's hoped the ski
will encourage more people to get
vaccinated
more than 3 million have made an
appointment to do so since it was
outlined a week ago
and that's all for this edition of your
kobe 19 special
thanks for watching stay safe
you